hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast about colony picking you
know fully automated DNA assembly
workflow presented by dr. Sheila to
cosas dr. agon un and dr. valantine
dual-core all from the edinburgh genome
foundry we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar hosted by
libraries and sponsored by molecular
devices molecular devices is one of the
world's leading providers of instrument
software and reagents for life science
research pharmaceutical and biocera
pubic development their broad product
portfolio includes automated microbial
colony pickers which will feature in
today's presentations the team at
Edinburgh genome foundry EGF have worked
closely with molecular devices automated
workflow engineering solutions or ODS
group who can tailor molecular devices
products according to individual
customer needs you can find out more
about the AHS group by visiting the
molecular devices website I am shooting
oracle a brutes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box it
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem thank you
now I'd like to introduce dr. Dakota dr.
UN and dr. Zola dr. Hiller Takota led
the design installation and
establishment on the robotic platform at
ETS she currently leads a team of
seven specialized staff to develop fully
automated DNA assembly for research and
commercial purposes doctor to closes
backgrounds in molecular and cell
biology and has always included
state-of-the-art technologies for cell
and high throughput biology dr. Ivan UN
has a PhD in molecular and cell biology
and has been involved in the setup of
all instrumentation in the EGF is a
talented biologist with expertise in
script writing and he has a very good
feel for the delicate equipment on the
platform dr. Valentin Zukor
has been developing software for
computer assisted design and
manufacturing at the EGF since 2015
after a PhD in systems biology from the
University Joseph Fourier and
engineering degrees in applied
mathematics from Ecole Centrale Paris
and TU Vienna is also a former
professional chip maker please join me
in welcoming dr. Checotah I will now
turn the presentation over to her thank
you very much for this opportunity to
present the Edinburgh genome foundry we
are a newly established facility for
synthetic biology at the University of
Edinburgh in Scotland DNA assembly is
one of the key processes to enable
synthetic biology and this can be easily
automated we would like you to give you
an overview of how this is done here
at the EGS we will put special emphasis
on our customized cubic select HT colony
picker and spreader from molecular
devices that you can see here in the
foreground a crucial step in DNA
assembly is the amplification of DNA in
bacteria or yeast the cue picks can
played out these cells on a car dishes
in the next day the individual colonies
for roll the cue picks is integrated
into our robotic platform and we will
describe the process in more detail
before let me just briefly present some
technology and why this field needs
platforms like the Edinburgh genome
foundry the
primary focus is synthetic biology
synthetic biology is about using genetic
paths to reprogram organisms to achieve
useful function the field has expanded a
lot in the past decade and I will give
one example of what it can do on the
left here you see the plant at a Mesa
annua also known as sweet wormwood for a
long time at a Michelin has been
isolated from this plant and been used
in traditional Chinese medicine at the
Mizanin has also been found to have
unfamiliar malarial properties however
it is not very practical and
cost-effective to isolate enough and
utter methanol to treat all malaria
patients with a plan isolate the
research group of Jay Keasling was able
to reprogram yeast to produce
anti-malarial drug artemisinin back in
2014 this required transforming the
whole genetic pathway to produce this
valuable and tumeric de Leiria direct
precursor in yeast this demonstrates the
enormous capacity of the technology in
the production of pharmaceutical agents
but it is also applicable to the
production of biofuels cosmetics
biosensors and much more developing new
synthetic biology products is a trial
and error process that typically takes
years it is generally broken down in
four phases design first test and learn
in the design phase genetic circuits are
designed based on requirements and prior
knowledge this produces the pathless and
sequences of the DNA to be assembled in
the build phase the circuits are
assembled from paths using one of
several available DNA assembly
techniques the assembled construct event
quality controlled and examined for
their function in the organism this is
also known as the test phase the new
experimental data then will be analyzed
by
partitions what systems colleges to
refine models and estimations and
therefore expanding the knowledge base
and allowing for better design in the
next iteration a constant trend in the
last decade has been to try and automate
each step of the synthetic synthetic
biology process automation allows for
lower error rates higher throughputs
higher precision cheaper production and
much more the build and test phases can
be automated using robotic lab
laboratory equipment and computer
assisted manufacturing software the
learn and design phases can be semi
automated using machine learning or
automatic design program the automation
of an experimental cycle was first
performed by Ross King and his lab in
Manchester in 2004 they have set up the
robot scientist was able to execute an
experimentation group and generate
hypotheses from the data this set the
path for more advanced robotic setups
like the Edinburgh genome foundry at the
Edinburgh genome foundry we perform all
steps of the cycle that we focus in
particular on the build and test phases
our robotic setup is designed to
accommodate many different DNA assembly
methods and we also have a fleet of
robots for quality control and
phenotypical assay the learning design
part of the process are generally met by
our customers in their specific research
demands at the University facility we
are here to provide the automated build
and test as a service the Edinburgh
genome foundry is part of a network of
foundries
that were funded by the Research
Council's UK as part of their synthetic
biology for growth program to
specifically accelerate synthetic
biology project in the UK while having
similar technologies each foundry has
different biological
areas of expertise for instance the
early um Institute specializes in plant
biology while the EGF closely works
together with the Center for mammalian
synthetic biology at the University of
Edinburgh UK foundries establishing a
tight collaborative environment
furthermore the EGF has international
partners to stay at the forefront of
technological development for example we
have worked with autodesk on a design
DNA design tool and we use software from
JTA we also have special partnerships
with DNA companies like IDT Thermal and
twist who provide the DNA path that we
assemble we also worked closely with
thermo Fisher and molecular devices on
the design and integration of our
automated platform this resulted in a
highly integrated platform with
cutting-edge technology that is very
modular and therefore easily
reconfigured to changing demands in
technology now ivan will explain to you
how we apply DNA assembly to the robotic
work sir we were going to detail into
the robotic chain that we use to build
and test and we will conclude with the
presentation of the software developed
to support the robotic operation thank
you so my name is Ivan I'm the
application specialist here in Edinburgh
genome foundry what that actually means
in reality is that my job boils down to
translating the science that the
boundaries that's how to do into actual
robotic operation so that the
instrumentation that we have can
actually do it and this includes the
molecular devices like youpix that I
will talk about in a little bit so what
I'm going to do in my segment here is
start off by describing the science and
the workflow that we use to assemble DNA
here at the head of a genome foundry and
then I'm going to I'm going to describe
the
the instrumentation that we have to do
it and then I'm going to highlight the
steps in the workflow that feature the
cue picks and show how the cue picks is
particularly well-suited for our
high-throughput large DNA assembly
processes
I'm going to start off here what you can
see here is is a workflow for assembling
DNA it's one of many but it is one that
we use quite often here at the EGF it's
called a essentially a GoldenGate
workflow or sometimes called a type 2
error restriction assembly method what
this basically involves is a selection
of DNA parts at the very story that's
what the cherry-pick part means one full
of the only parts are assembled in the
same physical tube a reaction mix allows
them to like a together into the final
DNA product now this DNA product is too
small and quantity to be useful to
anyone including our customers so what
we have to do at this point is to
introduce it into into bacteria what
called the transformation step now this
step is the the beginning of our of our
requirement for for the cubix instrument
because and it will involve plating out
of liquid suspensions of bacteria onto
solid agar plate and I'll describe in a
little bit later how the cue picks
helped us do that in high throughput and
reproducible fashion then after the
cells grill on the solid agar plates we
have to be able to amplify it and
extract the DNA so that we can ship it
off to the customers and again the cue
picks is used in this colony picking
process and it is very very good at
picking our vast numbers of colonies in
very short time and after this we then
extract the DNA from the cells that we
have cultured this is called the mini
pepper and then after this before we
ship it off to the customer we apply
quality control or QC by subjecting the
purified DNA CH an analytical digest and
capillary electrophoresis this is what
is referred to on this diagram and
digest and fragment analysis and
assuming that the DNA path is juicy
within happily shifted after are waiting
customers so I'm going to tell you a
little bit about the the golden gate
method or the type 2's restriction
enzyme assembly I'm not going to go into
graphic detail but I think it does help
so the difference between this type of
assembly and traditional conventional
restriction digest based assembly is
that it enables you to assemble multiple
DNA parts together in the one reaction
and at the same time is forces the the
spatial order in which these parts are
assembled so that you get assembly in a
particular order rather than a random
assemblage of different parts so the
difference between this type of assembly
and the conventional assembly is that
the enzyme that is used to cut the DNA
part out is has recognition sites that
are separate from the site at which it
actually cut the DNA so if I can show
you three different DNA parts being
joined together here what you'll notice
is that the region in which the enzyme
cut the DSMB one side is highlighted
here with the four letters n but the
recognition site for the enzyme is
actually separate from that so what that
means is if you're clever in choosing
that the sequences that are annotated
here at the n you can dictate the
overhangs that are produced at the end
of the DNA parts and these part also
these overhangs enforce the spatial
order in which these parts assemble in
other words if you look at parts one two
three here there is no possible way part
one could join on to part 3 directly
because the overhangs at the end of part
one are not complementary to the
overhangs at the start of part three so
here like I said we can join multiple
DNA parts together simultaneously and at
the same time we can enforce a spatial
order in which this occurs so here in
the Edinburgh genome foundry we have a
specialized toolkit to do this so we
have a huge library of parts all ready
to go and what we can do here is we can
assemble up to 25 different parts
together in a single reaction and we can
make sure that this occurs in a specific
order so our customers essentially tell
us what the number of parts that they
want assembled is and what that order is
and we essentially picked them out as
you would if you were if you were
selecting and filling for a fork or a
sandwich and then we piece it together
for them and they ship it off so this
toolkit is very flexible because it has
a huge assortment of promoters open
reading frames tags terminators that our
customers can pick and choose to suit
their scientific to suit their
scientific purposes and they can build
multiple transcription units using this
toolkit so it's actually possible using
this toolkit to produce up to three
transcription unit all the same time and
this represent essentially better value
for money so here in this segment I'm
going to tell you what instrumentation
we actually need to do the workflow that
I've just described and the very at the
very beginning of the process is liquid
handling so here's where we actually
select DNA part our customers actually
one and we pick and mix them together in
two different tubes as you'll see in the
animation
here so these would represent three
different assemblies because we can add
a portion of receiving vector to each of
these so that they produce three
different assemblies in the same plate
and for this we have the liquid handlers
that you can see in the upper right hand
corner we have a lab site echo which is
an acoustic dispenser and as a pair
actually of t-con our evil 202 carry out
most of these liquid handling yet we
also have a blob dispenser called the
circus now once the DNA assemblies are
mixed in the tube we add some enzyme
where they do their magic and assemble
the DNA together and then the next step
as I mentioned earlier is to get this
tiny little amount of assembled DNA into
bacteria so that it can be amplified and
this happens during a transformation
process where the DNA goes from the
reaction into the bacteria which is
e.coli and now this is the bit where the
cue picks comes in because we have to be
able to spread the bacterial cell
suspensions on to a solid agar plate so
this is really an example of the agar
plates that we use so here we would use
eight different regions on this on this
plate to maximize the number of
different DNA assemblies that we can fit
into the same container and the q-tips
helps us do that because it has a liquid
handling portion that can produce a
different droplet on this plate and then
it has a plating head which produces
which uses eight different pins to
spread that liquid very evenly across
the surface of the agar now this is very
important because it's it's essential
for making sure that the cells are not
overly dense or overly dilute and so
that they can be picked very accurately
a reaper
later so once that is done we leave them
overnight so that they can form separate
colonies like you see in this picture
here and then this is the bit where we
have to select the colonies and pick
them physically pick them off the plate
and put them into a new plate where they
can grow and where we can use this
culture to extract their DNA later and
again the queue picks is an instrument
is essential for us to be able to do
this in a high-throughput fashion
because if you think about it there's a
huge number of colonies that are
required to be picked we pick a huge
number because we have to be able to
guarantee that we pick at least one that
contains the correct assembly so the
queue picks again uses a very
specialized set of heads with metal pins
and they have 96 pins per head so that
means that per round of picking it can
pick up to 96 individual colonies from
these from these agar plates and then
put them into what you see here as
essentially a plate of growth medium so
that the bacteria that they have picked
and can grow so that we can extract the
DNA the following morning
so this is how the this is how a cartoon
representation of how the pickin happens
and after the growth we would then
subject it to what we call an analytical
restriction enzyme digest now this is
the first QC statin are in our workflow
where we have to make sure that the DNA
that has assembled is in the correct
order and contains the correct parts so
we do this by cutting the the purified
DNA up using
action of restriction enzymes that are
selected by our software development
team once it gets cut up we will
basically end up with a number of
different fragments of different sizes
and you can predict based on the
assembly before you actually do this
reaction what these sizes are so then it
is a matter of determining the size to
determine the size we use capillary
electrophoresis or what's what can also
be called fragment analysis so our
instrument is called the fragment
analyser it's made by Adi and this
picture which looks very busy here
represents 96 individual digests so
these represent 96 different clones of
different assemblies and as you can see
it is a very complex pattern and I
really I hope you can appreciate from
this slide just the amount of throughput
that is required here at the foundry so
all of the instrumentation that we use
from colony picking to capillary
electrophoresis to liquid handlers they
all have to be capable of very high
throughput and in a way this is one of
the reasons why we picked the cubix is
our colony picker of choice because
there are other colony Pickers out on
the market which produce this well which
through the same processes but many of
them use a single pin to do this so is
compared to the cue picks which uses 96
pins they are much much slower and it's
a great way to well it's great for me to
be able to save so much time picking and
plating using the cubix as opposed to a
single pin picker so as you can imagine
with any high-throughput process we
handle everything in place not intrude
so here in the IGF we have three
different sizes of plates which
basically increased the amount of
throughput that we can have we go from
96 to 380
four to 1536 wealth and at the moment we
focus predominantly on DNA assembly
using 96 and 384 well format but
obviously in future for the purposes of
saving on reagents 1536 would be the
best way to go so what I'm going to do
here to finish off is I'm going to
describe our robotic platform in other
words the actual hardware that we use
and how it all links together in our in
our automated platform so what you can
see here is basically a cartoon
schematic of our of our platform so the
basic design revolves around putting all
of the instrumentation which you see in
these different white shapes and linking
them all together using a series of
industrial robotic arms that travel on
track so the robotics are the robotic
arms you can actually see and hear
certain positions on the track and the
black lines in the middle represent the
tracks along which the robot arms can
travel to reach the individual
instrument so I'm going to start off by
showing you these robotic arms so these
robotic arms actually provided by
thermal scientific they are a repurposed
fluke robotic arm in a different setting
you would find these Finnegan spray
paint in your car or doing spot weld but
for us these robotic arms are very
flexible and they enable us to have the
reach and that we need to be able to
reach the wide range of of instruments
that are on our track so we have the
liquid handlers that I described earlier
so these are highlighted here we have
the T Knievel's which produce the
petting capacities that we would need
for nuclear gas extraction the
transformations that I mentioned earlier
and a whole range of other things for
low volume DNA assembly so the mixing of
the points we use the lab
right echo 550 which is an acoustic
dispenser and for bulk filling of
reagents we have a Geiger service here
now we also have a collection of PCR
machine these are these are the machines
in which the ligation reactions actually
occurs so we have a little collection of
tea robots which are made by biometry
and a collection of life cycler is made
by Rush we also have of course our
molecular devices cue picks which is
located at the very end of our platform
and the back panel of the instrument is
removed to allow access from the rear
for the robotic arms to deliver
consumable and in a fully automated way
we have alternated storage again
everything on the platform is automation
compatible so we can store consumables
and plate in various different positions
inside inside the psychomat and we can
also grow the cells that we we need so
if you remember for the nucleic acid
extraction process we actually need to
grow the cells that the colony picker
the two picks actually picks so they
grow overnight at 37 degrees in one of
these title maps here we have
centrifuges which are bizarrely enough
centrifuges and we also have a
collection of plate sealers and which
basically allow us to seal the plate
before a growth for example so they
allow gas permeable seals to be applied
to the plate so that the cells that we
grow they don't expect siate overnight
so the reverse of this is a peeler and
we also have a peeler that would
basically reduce all the peels and that
the sealers apply and again this this
all this was designed with full
automation in mind so that all the
processes that you can basically do at
the bench you can also and do here on
the automated platform we have delivers
which removes the lids to the agar plate
so this is a key bit of instrument
that allows the cupids to function in a
high throughput capacity because we can
feed huge numbers of plates agar plate
into the cue picks in a fully automated
fashion because we can just stack them
into a carousel and walk away because
all the living and the deleting will
occur automatically part of the
automated platform we also have cold
storage these are cryo vials these are
essentially bar coded individually bar
coded feeder tubes in which we store the
bacterials stocks in our -80 long-term
storage and this machine this through
that dekappa dekap ER is part of our
automated solution for moving and adding
the lid we also have a flexible input
hotel which allows us to put any kind of
consumable into the system while it is
in operation and we also have a barcode
label
which allows us to barcode and therefore
track all of the consumables we have on
the platform we have a large number of
storage capacity which resides in our
carousels we have three of these and you
can store anything that you would want
to use hitboxes a dark place anything
that you can think of in the lab in
these carousel and on that note I'm
going to hand over to Hillier again
who's going to tell you about some of
the specific features of our of our cue
pics HD select system yes I even have
explained very well how the cue pics
into our workflow and I would like to
make this a bit more visual for you now
so this is our two bricks and you see
the automated platform in the background
there and we work very closely with the
thermal design team and the oil team for
molecular devices to build the FIR
integrated cue pigs so for this first of
all the back panel was removed so that
the panel robot arm had access to the
two pigs and we also ordered a
toothpicks 420 which usually doesn't
have a placing capability but ours has
has and it also has the plating
capability on SBS plates on only trays
with a gap we square ones you saw in
Ivan's presentation which usually the
toothpicks didn't take they take two
petri dishes or only trays but we also
have the option of using it manually
without the whole robotic platform and
use the other plate format it also has
fluorescent imaging allowing us to
distinguish between different
fluorescent markers and also a barcode
reader because we need to track all
samples this is what the pinning had
looked a plating had looked like that
Ivan mentioned with this we can plate
out the cells in the eight fears and to
show you how this works we have a short
movie which I'm going to show you now
and that explains the whole process of
plating
[Applause]
you
the colonies then grow overnight in the
incubator in the next day they go back
to the colony picker where they are
imaged and we get this kind of image so
the colony picker
identifies individual colonies and here
in yellow you see the colonies that are
isolated enough to be picked and in red
some that will not be picked because
they are too too close together and
might not be single colonies we then can
pick them with a speaking head that has
a tyvan set 96 different pins so 96
colonies get very quickly picked and
inoculated into the deep web place where
we grow up the cultures for miniprep
just to conclude on the robotic set up
in the test of our DNA assembly we also
have several other equipment to quality
control and to phenotypic assays for
example the sequel which is a new
sequencer from pack file and it's
especially good for large fragment
sequencing and also a high throughput
comenta from n to P labs the Robo
lecture where we can do many
fermentations in parallel to test
different DNA's in different cells and
the different conditions and also mass
spec that we use for example formative
elements with metabolomic are saying but
I don't want to go more into detail of
this in this seminar so I would like to
hand over to Valentin now who will talk
to you about the immense software thank
you hello and we are three software
engineers at the foundry and our role in
a nutshell is to automate everything we
can and in particular the
decision-making processes so that the
operation team spends less time worrying
about the details and can focus on the
big three
sure and developing new protocols so we
develop different kind of software for
databases and tracking for web
interfaces report generation and very
often we just write custom scripts for
some statistic protocols so in this
slide you can see a few tiles that are
performed by software in our process
first at the design stage we have web
services that provide information about
our genetic parse registry so customers
can know exactly what parts we have and
include this part in their assemblies
then once we receive assembly orders
which are their sequences or list of
parts to assemble we run several checks
first to ensure their assemblies are not
pathogenic and then to ensure they can
be manufactured without difficulties
then comes the assembly planning which I
will speak about in the next slides and
then you have the drill entered phases
for which we have software to try
example get data thousand Lots prod
different from different robots and then
verify from the data we get that
everything went according to the plan
and add for instance our assembly we'll
have the right sequence my next lives
will be to go into more details and
software operations that are just
upstream and downstream of the robotic
assembly and that is how we go from
customer design to planning the assembly
and then at the end how do we verify
verify the final assembly just before
shipping them back to the customer so
the first step is design and design
software and we have been collaborating
with autodesk on a new online
computer-aided design tool called
trinity constructor one specificity of
this software is that it's connected to
the EGS you can get parts directly from
the EGF part registry and when you are
happy with your design you can order
with a directly from this interface once
we receive the orders we run a few
checks and in particular which simulates
the cloning that is going to happen on
the robot to verify that all parts with
us will assemble together without
complications on all their hands or
restriction site and so on and so here
for instance you have a simulated
cloning we went from 12 parts and we
simulate
what will happen when we put these 12
flowers on the receptor vector so
another another advantage of the
simulated cloning is that you get the
final expected sequence of their
assembly so once you have the sequence
for each assembly we are going to make
another thing we can do is choose the
enzyme or the combination of enzyme that
we will use to digest and verify our
assemblies so to keep protocol
simple we try to find just one digestion
that will produce nice band patterns for
all the assemblies in the assembly bed
batch and so that means we want patterns
with at least 2 or 3 bands and
preferably bands that are in the good
sensitivity zone of the migration gel so
we have algorithms that go look into
every possible combination of on them
and choose an optimal one and another
thing we can do in advance if predict
all many clones should be picked for
each assembly so the idea here is that
if you have a complex assembly then you
have more chances to have sequence
artifacts in the end so you should pick
more clones to make sure that is one of
these clothes will have the correct
assembly so the data I'm showing here is
a bit old and pulled actually one of our
first assembly batches but the ID and
the idea is really progressively refine
our models with the new data that we
acquire from from our setup but so in
these plots here what you can see on the
left is the assembly successes in green
or failures in red plotted as a function
of the complexity of the assembly we
have their assembly size number of base
pairs on one axis and the number of
parts in the other axis and so here's
the correlation between the complexity
of the assemblies and the success it's
not very strong but globally you can
notice that assemblies with less than 15
parts tend to success a lot and
assemblies with more than 15 parts of
our lower success probability so from
this data we can draw a map of expected
success and that I mind for future
constructs almost close should get
and that's what you have on the right
it's an app that enables us to predict
from the complexity of our ads and these
are mini clone should we pick then the
last step before the actual assembly on
the robots is to produce protocol file
that can be read by robots the first
step to this is first locate the
position of each genetic part and for
this we use an open-source central
manager called ice which is developed by
JD in San Francisco once we know exactly
what fridge and plate and what location
on the place each genetic part is we
need to list all the liquid dispense
things that are necessary to make the
assembly so for instance if you have 96
assemblies to do on the plate and if you
have 15 parts for each assembly in
average then you have around 1,500
liquid transfers to perform so you list
them and then we export it at least in
machine format either chicken Evo or eco
and we send that list to the robots and
so to make all this we have a library
developed at the EGS called Plato which
makes it easy to define pick lists to
export the tick list in two different
formats for different robots to generate
reports with maps of every intermediary
plate and also want a very useful thing
that does is it simulates the pick list
to make sure that we won't have any well
over capacity or we won't have any
problem with dead volumes in the world
so that when we send the file to the
robot we know approximately what to
expect and we we know there won't be any
problem then you have the drills the
proper build and so during the build we
have software to track everything to
deliver barcodes and for instance we
have an Android app that enables you to
scan the barcode and the app is linked
to ours and told managers so that you
know exactly the full information of the
plate when you wanna scan the barcode so
once the absently is done you get a
first quality control data that you get
is a fragment analyze it and so we're
really lucky enough
have an automated fragment analyzer and
what that means is that we get actual
data not pictures but actual data which
is the size of the different dents so
represented here is a verification of
three cloves from the same assembly in
the in blue on the left you have the
expected band for this construct then
you have three band pageants two which
have your correct in green and one sorry
and and one is the middle that is
clearly wrong and because we would check
lots of clone typically if you have 96
assembly we will take maybe five hundred
clones so we try to make it very as easy
as possible to spot good and wrong
clones with the green and red color
scheme but we can we also try to provide
as many informations as possible with
this reports so that even assembly is
consistently broke and as consistent
consistently wrong band we can deduce
which part may be 14 that the figure you
have like on the lower side it basically
tells you exactly where ensign cut the
end I've discussed that if you have the
wrong burn we can try to deduce where it
didn't cut and so what part was not
inserted as it should have been and so
finally we have verification of Sanger
sequencing so here we could use I mean
we do use Tenderheart alignment method
that's what you have on the first figure
but same here if you have 96 construct
or two to verify at once we needed
something a bit simpler to to to tribal
and so we went with with custom software
that simply tells you exactly what's
your reads world where the primers
annealed and what the perfect match
perfect sequencing spans were so that
you can see at a glance if your full
construed was covered in it because
writing you can check it and marketed as
done and sequenced as a final word at
the foundry like we try to really that
much as software as we can on the
internet and so all these software that
I thought about is or will be soon
released on github and we try to package
that
into small very focused and easy-to-read
libraries so that you can use these
libraries to build your own biological
application even if your workflow or end
goal is not exactly similar to ours
[Applause]
Thank You Ballentine so that so much for
the software development and I hope
you've got a good idea of what the
Edinburgh genome foundry is like and
possibly can do for you please contact
us if you have any questions all this of
course wouldn't have been possible with
a very good team spirit this is our team
here you now have heard myself valentin
and ivan but they are also our to other
software developers i ii i to amaze our
designer who designed our logo and many
other things around the foundry
including this presentation and the
movie and scott newsn our very talented
modern apprentice and tara our
automation engineer the foundry wouldn't
have happened if our cool founding
directors
Susan and Patrick wouldn't have had the
idea of an automated foundry Patrick did
his postdoc ingest burkas lab and
therefore was exposed to a lot of DNA
assembly and that's where the idea of an
automated foundry was born and we are
very happy to have this going now so
thank you very much
and please ask your questions thank you
got to co-chair dr. UN and dr. Zook over
for your informative presentations it is
time for Q&A if you have a question
you'd like to ask our presenters please
do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question is the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for let's
get started our first question is
you somehow pre-screen your colonies
before picking them or is it a random
kick wow that's that's a good question
actually
we're the cubix instrument that we have
is set up to be able to do a pre-screen
because as they are for essence turrets
that allows us the image or the colonies
for flesh turns before we don't
currently do that but as definitely
something that we will do in the future
I want to advise that poll questions
will appear on your screen and you may
select your answers then close the poll
questions by clicking on the X in a
right corner
our next question is what success rate
do you have for each assembly approach
and how many clones need to be to
achieve any assembly idea
yeah so that again it's a fairly
variable number so the success rate for
our the gold the Golden Gate assembly a
method I described in the webinar that
had a success rate that starts off at
about 90 percent for a small number of
parts around six and obviously with the
the greater the number of parts you have
the the lower the success rate so that
success rate drops to about 40-something
percent when you have a highly complex
assembly which is about twelve twenty
parts and the number of clones that we
would have to pick is therefore
inversely proportional to the success
rate so we would typically pick anywhere
between 6 to 12 colonies per construct
to be fairly confident that we would
have at least one good one
what ligase and buffers do you typically
work with oh those are those are fairly
box standard on the like AIDS reaction
for the common gate that we describe
uses standard t4 ligase buffer I believe
we get as many B
it's a very bulk standard t4 ligase it's
not even a quickly I guess it's just the
regular the regular cheap stuff
you forgot the software can decide how
many colonies to kick but what is the
typical number and again it's kind of
like what I am what I described earlier
it varies based on the complexity of the
assembly but typically it varies between
Victor do you think this is an area of
research that will receive more funding
over the next few years yes definitely I
mean synthetic biology is one of the
really big growing research field and
the foundry and other foundries are an
essential tool for this to develop new
medicines biofuels and so on so I think
yes there will be more funding where do
most of your customers come from and are
you able to provide services outside the
UK say in Belgium at the moment we put a
little bit into setting up phase so
mostly we interact with researchers at
the University of Edinburgh but in the
long term we definitely expect to have
customers from all over the UK and
hopefully all over the world does ice
generate our codes for the plates and
samples could you repeat that yes
just ice generate barcodes for the plate
and samples absolutely yes so basically
the the automation system the scheduler
queries ice
so we've interfaced ice together with
the schedulers so that a runtime we
query ice and ice generates the barcode
sends it to the scheduler the scheduler
sends it to the barcode printer and we
print at one time you do run a car on
plates
we do indeed it can be a fairly arduous
process but we do indeed we just it's
it's a very booked standard process we
take molten agar and we we pour it in in
a Omni tray which are the square
asteroid the rectangular SBS size
containers as you saw earlier it it does
have to be fairly consistent it has to
be fairly flat because the the Q picks
doesn't like plates obviously which are
very bumpy or very uneven but it is a
manual process yes which software and
equipment generate the information and
label about the sample and is the ice
repository is it the ice repository or
anything else it depends on depends on
what you mean by information label but
if you mean and what parts have to go
into and assembly yes without is done by
querying the ice database so the ice
database essentially has all of our
parts it doesn't contain information
about which parts can fit together to
make a viable assembly we have the
software development team has their own
custom software to do that but it all
Mindi at the software level it all
depends on ice because the ice
repository has all of the parts so all
of the software that's written by the
sovereignty queries ice to get bar
coding information batch information and
as well sequencing information okay well
while we're waiting for additional
questions to come in I would once again
like to thank dr. Costa
dr. UN and doctors real or for their
presentations let me just see one moment
yes okay yeah I think I think that will
be it for questions right now I would
also like to thank our sponsor molecular
devices for making today's educational
Cass possible this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CC button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits and
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through October 6
2017 you'll receive an email from
laggards letting you know in this
webcast will be available for replay
please show that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon
goodbye